the coronavirus developments is CBS news
medical contributor dr. David agus dr.
agus let's start with REM de severe and
we know that it's not the Silver Bullet
but what can you tell us about why this
is having an impact and how that may
impact other drugs that they're looking
at as far as treatment going forward so
REM decid originally developed for Ebola
but works in this disease about a
four-day shorter hospitalization and 30%
reduction in death rate when given to
people who either have pneumonias on
x-ray or who are really short of breath
so classically with viral drugs when you
treat really seriously ill patients they
work okay but when you move it earlier
they work dramatically better so very
exciting for the first time I can walk
into a patient's room and said I have a
drug that I think will benefit you I
couldn't do that really until this week
so it really is an optimistic positive
moment in the fight against this disease
and we will take everything right now
one of the things that also came out
late at the end of this week and really
stands out is this idea that it could be
two more years with the University of
Minnesota study saying that it could be
two more years before we have this herd
immunity and that feels a so long away
and how do we get to that point you're
talking about two thirds of the world
and right now we're talking about still
sheltering in place so how do we get
there well it's a one-word answer I mean
a very very simple word vaccine vaccine
vaccine vaccine and this week we heard
very positive news out of Oxford
University about a vaccine that when
given to monkeys they were then
challenged with the virus and for 28
days no symptoms at all and this vaccine
is being scaled because there's a very
similar vaccine that had been used for
another virus so it's kind of skipping
some of the early safety studies and
going into 6,000 patients over the next
month and then will expand dramatically
and they're already starting production
of millions of doses so the hope is that
by the end of the summer there millions
of doses available and it's been shown
to work there about a hundred other
efforts with vaccines going on across
the globe
so major effort to vaccinate which will
dramatically increase herd immunity in
the world and that obviously feels again
like that is far away and that's where
we want to get to but what about
in the meantime dr. agus we've heard so
much about we need to have more testing
in order to live with this disease and
open up as some states are doing right
now where do we stand in that regard
well Dana you and I have had this
discussion unfortunately many times over
the last weeks is that we need a lot
more testing in this country we need
testing for who has the virus and we
still in the United States of America do
not have a test for immunity that is who
had the virus and is immune at the
present time so those are critical in my
mind to safe opening you know we saw a
few minutes ago a meatpacking plant that
was testing employees before they came
in and that is awesome we need to do
more of that in this country and do we
call surveillance testing testing groups
of patients in different racial
backgrounds different ethnic backgrounds
different parts of the city to see where
asymptomatic cases lie so we can go in
those areas and basically stay at home
there so we don't spread antibody test
is key thank you dr. David agus